- Bless me, Lord, for I am going to sin.
(choir music plays)
- [Narrator] Midnight Mass
is the latest addition
to writer-director, Mike
Flanagan's horror repertoire.
(door creaks)
Let's take a look at how Midnight Mass
is connected to Hill House
and other Flanagan titles.
(choir music plays)
Many fans have speculated
that, like the work
of one of Flanagan's role
models, Stephen King,
all of Flanagan's film
and television projects
are connected as part of a larger MFCU,
Mike Flanagan Cinematic Universe,
or the Flanaverse for short.
The Haunting of Hill House
and The Hunting of Bly Manor
were both based on pieces
of classic literature:
Shirley Jackson's 1959 novel,
The Haunting of Hill House,
and Henry James' 1898 novella,
The Turning of The Screw, respectively.
Midnight Mass is separate
from The Haunting anthology
and is not based on classic literature.
If you're a true MFCU fan,
you already know that
Flanagan makes reference
to Midnight Mass in two of his films,
Hush and Gerald's Game.
(groans)
- Get the fuck away!
- I finished your book.
What did I think? I loved Riley.
I loved Erin. They were great.
- [Narrator] Casting is
the most obvious connection
between Midnight Mass and
Flanagan's other productions.
Kate Siegel, one of Flanagan's
most frequent collaborators
and wife, stars in the series.
- Then city council, were
you will be, kind of,
but not really slut-shamed by Bev Keane.
- Ah.
- Dad, don't give this woman our money.
(furniture rattles)
- I thought I told you not
to play around in here.
- [Narrator] Henry Thomas,
another Flanaverse regular,
also plays an important role.
- So church isn't for you, huh?
- Well, I didn't know that
they were all gonna die.
- [Narrator] Several
other Flanagan favorites
grace Midnight Mass.
- They know that.
- Let's calm down a bit.
- You be calm, Leigh. It's
not your name in here.
- [Narrator] This includes Annabeth Gish.
- Are you ready for this?
- Sarah Gunning. You're...
...I've heard about you, Father.
- [Narrator] Rahul Kohli.
- Was he afraid of it,
intrigued by it, or?
- Well, you have to warn me, don't you?
You have to help me.
- [Narrator] Alex Essoe.
- What is it?
- There's someone in
my room and it's a boy.
- (groans) Miles.
- [Narrator] Robert Longstreet.
- They had none of that.
- If you as a fisherman...
- Probably ain't my place,
but maybe she could use
a little time away from the house.
- [Narrator] Michael Trucco.
- Thought we could all use a refresher.
- All right, I'm going
to put my phone down,
reach for my wallet, okay?
Take it easy.
- [Narrator] Carla Gugino.
- It is the sentence of this court
that you be incarcerated
for a period of four to 10 years
in the custody of the Illinois
Department of Corrections.
- Can we have a tea party?
- Not now. Young lady?
- Please-o-please?
- No. Come with me right now.
- [Narrator] Fun fact, five
actors from Midnight Mass appear
in Flanagan's next
series, The Midnight Club.
Zach Gilford, Igby Rigney, Annarah Cymone,
Matt Biedel, Crystal
Balint, and Samantha Sloyan,
which follows terminally ill teens
who meet up to tell scary stories.
- Shit.
- [Narrator] The Midnight Club is based
on a book by Christopher Pike.
Pike is also a name used in Midnight Mass.
- Pike.
- His name was Pike.
- [Narrator] The haunted
mirror from Flanagan's movie,
Oculus, appears as an Easter
egg in many of his works.
In Midnight Mass, the mirror
is on stage in the rec center
where Riley attends AA meetings.
Flanagan himself makes
a cameo in episode three
and sings in the choir.
- May I see your permit?
Where are you going? Right this way.
- [Narrator] Composer Andy
Grush, of the Newton brothers
who have composed music
for every Flanagan project since 2013,
appears as the resident
musician of Crockett Island.
Look and listen closely for
more Flanaverse connections
when you watch Midnight
Mass, only on Netflix.